could you shed some light on what are
the implications of the term fast or s s
is Arabic word which is singular is
plural s or in Arabic is derived from
the word Sama which means to abstain or
to restrain from the normal things
whether it be eating drinking or talking
and a person who observes some or
abstain from these things is called as a
and this word is used in the Quran in
Sur chapter number 19 verse number 26
when the angel speaks to Mary may Allah
be pleased with her who is the mother of
Jesus Christ please be upon him and this
word is used and if you read this word
says that I have vowed to fast to
Allah but here the meaning of the word s
fast doesn't mean ref refraining from
eating or drinking it means refraining
from speaking because when we go to the
context when we read one verse before in
the Quran Surah maram chapter number 19
verse number 25 it says that Allah subh
says to Mary may Allah that shake the
palm tree towards yourself and the ripe
dates will fall and the next verse suram
chapter 19: 26 says eat and drink from
them and and then it says that when you
meet any human being tell them I have
vowed to fast for Allah and I will not
speak to any human being so because here
it says about speaking the word s used
here means that to abstain from
speaking but the word s in Islamic
terminology in the Islamic Sharia it
means a
person who does an act of
worship
and with intention he does it for the
sake of Allah subhana tala and he or she
abstains from eating drinking or
nourishment as well as from sexual
intercourse or from lustful s
ejaculation in short the word s in Islam
means a person who abstains from the
fast breakers and the fast breakers the
things that break the fast are food
whether taken by mouth or by nose or
drink any kind of drink whether it be
water milk fruit juice any drink taken
from mouth or nose or any nourishment
for the body taking from any
source as well as abstaining from a
sexual
intercourse in short it means
abstaining the stomach and the private
part this is what it means
islamically
and this is the basic meaning but if you
go ahead with the broader meaning it
does not mean only abstaining the
stomach and the sexual part from the
things that break the fast it even means
that along with the fasting of the
stomach and the sexual parts there is
fasting of the tongue of the eyes of the
ears and the other limbs of the body
that the reason when we use the word s
our beloved Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam said it's mentioned
inkari volume number three in the book
of fasting Hadith number 1903 a beloved
Prophet said that a person who does not
abstain does not leave false action and
false speech obsin Etc Allah does not
require of him to abstain from food and
drink that means beside abstaining from
food and drink you also have to abstain
from false speech false actions Etc and
this message is further repeated my
beloved Prophet M wasallam our beloved
Prophet MMI wasallam said in ofum number
one number
1068 Bel Prophet said that a
person while fasting when he abstains
from food and drink he should also
abstain from forse speech from obscene
language and if a person gets angry and
if he argues with him or fights with him
he should say I'm fasting I'm
fasting so if he look at it when a
person fast there are basically three
things that he should abstain from
number one is the stomach and the
private parts they should
abstain from things that break the fast
that is food drink and sexual AC the
second is that the other parts of the
body the tongue the eyes the ears the
limbs even they should
fast fasting of the tongue means a
person should abstain from backbiting
should abstain from slandering from
telling a
lie should abstain from gossiping
abstain from rumor
mongering abstain from
vulgarity fasting of the eyes means he
should abstain from looking at things
which are
unlawful like when he sayam he should
lower his gaze he should not not watch
un Islamic
movies or un Islamic things fasting of
the years means should abstain from
hearing things which are Haram which are
prohibited like abstain from listening
to music abstain from listening to songs
which are un
Islamic so this is the way how the other
parts of the body also fast and the
third thing is the fasting of the heart
and the mind they should AB stained from
things which take away person from the
worship of Allah from the vi of Allah so
this orall is the meaning of the word
s